wayne cousins spoke only to confirm his  name and address he was dressed  in a grey tack suit and sat down  as details of the evidence that had been  put to the crown prosecution service  was relayed in court most of the time he  sat in court five with his head  bowed occasionally looking up and at the  end of the  short hearing which was delayed because  of a delayed arrival here  at westminster magistrates court the  chief magistrate  of the country senior district judge  paul goldspring  told him that he would have to be dealt  with at the old bailly that he would be  remanded in custody to appear there  on the 16th of march which  is tuesday so a short hearing he's back  in custody now  until he appears there what we also  found out during  that short hearing was that actually he  was charged last night  at 8 45 p.m having been  arrested on tuesday it was the following  day of course that sarah everard's  remains  were found in woodland near ashford  in kent